[Music]
let's go girls
yeah i love shania do you have a
favorite shania twain song
[Music]
probably who's bad
i think that's my fave
and our new fave is tyler hubbard's
debut solo single 5 foot 9.
did you expect your fans to react so
strongly to 5'9 because we all love that
song you know
uh i don't know what i expected i hoped
that they would that they would but no i
think there was
you just never know until it's out so
once it was out and i was getting you
know seeing the reaction i was so
excited it felt so good and uh yeah i
mean that's a special song and i loved
it people it was special for me now this
is inspired by your lady haley right it
is okay so what was her reaction when
you first played this for her she loved
it and uh she also reminded me that i'm
not sure if this is about me but i'm
actually 510 and i said okay well there
you have it so i'm sorry
i was just guessing honey my bad
yes tyler is starting a new chapter
without his florida georgia land
bandmate brian kelly with their
performance at the festival being one of
their last for now
so it's been fun to uh to kind of get to
reintroduce myself and and kind of move
the music along with my life you know
and let it be very personal and i find
that fans a lot of fans have told me
that they feel like they get to grow
with me which is really it makes me feel
good it's really cool
[Music]